hundreds of protesters have taken to the
streets of sydney today to demand
immediate action on climate change they
want full renewable power by 2030 they
want an end to coal power they want
pledges on methane and there's also been
a protest going on in melbourne as well
lots of disappointment here from
australia's actions so far at cop26 of
course australia didn't join that pledge
to cut methane they also haven't been
among the countries pledging to move
away from coal power but it's a very
different message in communities like
this one i'm in the upper hunter valley
in new south wales in one of the coal
mining communities there are mines
dotting the landscape around me this is
the main
train line which carries the coal
through the state and when i've been
speaking to people here involved in the
industry they say well it brings us
really good jobs we've got great wages
they invest in the community we don't
think we need to be moving away from
coal for 20 to 30 to even 50 years in
the future they are very determined to
carry on the message coming out of these
communities is if people around the
world want coal australia will sell it